When we talk about this taqiyya
business, what's interesting is that the
entire Quran, the revelation as it's
called, if you don't know the Quran
amongst Muslims, they believe that it
was revealed in piecemeal, okay? All the
ayahs and the surahs, and they were
later collated, you know, from the
longest to the shortest, not
chronologically. But the idea is they
were revealed in piecemeal over what?
First revelation start what? 610.
Muhammad dies in 632, so 22 years, okay?
And as is well known, if you look at the
early revelations, when Muhammad was in
Mecca and was weak and outnumbered and
couldn't do much of anything, couldn't
really go on the offensive, you get a
lot of peaceful verses, okay? And these
are the ones that the apologists are
fond of quoting nowadays. And Tony, what
are you talking about? Islam says, you
know, you have your religion, I have my
religion, there's no compulsion in
religion, and other verses, okay? But
then as time goes by, Muhammad becomes
stronger, well, all of a sudden Allah
starts giving him different revelations,
which become which also become stronger.
So then all of a sudden, um
the early verses, when Muslims were
completely weak, they were actually told
not to fight back or even to resist.
They were seen as a nuisance. Muhammad
was seen as a nuisance. But as he became
stronger, then their second phase is and
there's in the Quran, you can even see
these in the actual Quranic verses. The
second phase is now you can fight back,
but still don't start aggression. Then
he goes to Medina and becomes stronger,
becomes a warlord.
And it's at that point you get the final
word, which is, okay, now you can go on
the offensive, even if they don't start
the hostilities, cuz you're strong
enough.
So it's sort of remarkable,
um but basically, what we're seeing here
is that the Quran itself, its actual
revelation in sequence, is a testimony
to taqiyya.
Isn't it? And this is really not
surprising when one considers that Allah
himself, God, is actually described, I
think at least three times. I know one
of the verses is you can look up 3:54
Surah 3 a 54 and I think maybe 8:30. But
God is described Yeah, and it's good to
call it call him God so you understand
how Muslims see the supreme being Allah.
He's described as the greatest makkar.
You know what a makkar is? It's kind of
like it's a deceiver, a trickster,
someone who or one of the best words is
a schemer. Someone who schemes and
plots. Almost like a Loki figure. All
right? The Muslim God is described as
that and that's a compliment to him
supposedly. Okay, so it's not shocking
to find that taqiyya is so integral to
Islam. It was so innate to Muhammad and
even in the actual revelation of the
Quran itself, we see taqiyya. All right?
All of this we can see is what I'm
talking about for those who don't know.
It's called the naskh wal-mansukh. Okay?
This is the the idea of the verses that
are abrogated and the abrogated and the
abrogator. Like which verse abrogates
another? And so the idea is the later
verse because it comes out later
abrogates the earlier verse. And as we
just saw, the the later verses are the
violent ones. So the very very final
verses in Muhammad's life are the most
violent. For example, 9:5 which is known
as the sword verse which basically to
paraphrase it is you know, when when the
forbidden months are over lay in wait
and ambush for the for the polytheist,
the infidel.
And wait
lay in wait, ambush, kill them, take
them captive, do whatever to them. Okay?
It's known as the sword verse and that
verse alone is believed to have
abrogated I forget something like a
hundred verses, more peaceful verses.
And also with it, also 9 Surah 9 Surah
Tawbah 9:29
says fight the people of the book who
were told are somehow have a privileged
status with Muslims. People of the book
would be Christians and Jews, people who
have scriptures. Fight them until they
pay tribute and know their place and
live in subjection or you kill them.
Until So, that's the three choices given
to a Jew or a Christian, right? You
convert or we fight to the death or you
you you accept your place in society as
a second-class dhimmi, not the most
enviable lot, obviously. Check out my
Substack. Think about subscribing
because I plan on putting what I'm
telling you today
into a long long article or essay with
the sources, if you want the sources, um
if you don't trust me, right?
So, now
now we come to it.
So, the fact that Islam legitimizes
deception during war, of course, is not
that shocking, right? Like I mentioned,
this is very normal. I mean, who doesn't
engage in deception? All's fair in love
and war, isn't that the saying by some
Elizabethan writer, I believe? John
something. And all sorts of non-Muslim
Western philosophers, Eastern
philosophers, Sun Tzu, Machiavelli,
Thomas Hobbes, they all justified, of
course, deception during war. Now, the
crucial difference between Islam is that
war is a perpetual affair with the
infidel. So, if I'm always at war with
the infidel and deception is okay when
I'm at war, what does that mean? Then
deception is okay at all times against
the infidel.
So, that's the That's the little trick.
Now, here's a quote I I like, and this
is again when I was at the Library of
Congress, we had the old um edition of
the Encyclopedia of Islam, which was
actually pretty good. It was objective
and scholarly and didn't engage in
political correctness the way the new
version of the Encyclopedia of Islam
does.
And I'm not sure what the year is, but
it was the entry for jihad written by
Emile Tyan, he writes the following
quote, "The duty of the Jihad exists as
long as the universal domination of
Islam has not been attained." Okay? Look
at that. The duty of Jihad doesn't end.
It exists as long as the universal
domination of Islam has not been
attained. In other words, Jihad goes on
until the whole world is conquered. He
continues, "Peace with non-Muslim
nations is therefore a provisional state
of affairs only.
The chance of circumstance alone can
justify it temporarily."
Okay? So, the Islamic worldview is to
conquer the world. And that's
altruistic, of course, from their
mentality, right? And we're bringing the
lights of Islam to the world, and Islam
is not out to be partners or coexist
with anyone else, any other belief
system. It's out to take over and guide
humanity into the right path, okay? And
as such, only when Muslims are weak and
they need a um
reprieve because there's nothing they
can do, can they make treaties and
truces, okay? And it's supposed to be 10
years only, and then you're supposed to
reassess after 10 years. Now, if you're
a perpetually weaker, as in the modern
era, obviously it keeps renewing. And
I'm not saying that that they meet every
10 years, but it's just understood that,
"Okay, we're weak and there's nothing we
can do about it. So, we're not going to
go on the Jihad." But as you saw,
according to that quote from the
encyclo- the the the prestigious
encyclopedia of Islam when it was
prestigious and when it was
authoritative, makes it clear that war
is a non-stop affair, okay?
And um so, if that's the case, then like
I said, and deception is okay in war
because war is deceit, and the infidel
world is at war.
And to remind you, of course, the idea,
the classical understanding, is that,
you know, there's two dollars, two
abodes, Dar al-Islam, the abode of Islam
as it's called or the house of Islam,
which signifies the Islamic world
wherever Sharia is in charge. That's how
they understand it. That's the whole
idea by the way. You hear about Sharia
in the news. It's interesting, isn't it?
And the idea for Muslims is as long as
Sharia is in charge, then you don't have
to be a Muslim. You can be like we said,
and you can be a Christian or a Jew, pay
tribute, just know your place. And as
long as so the goal is not to convert
the world to Islam. That is that's not
true. The goal is that Sharia, meaning
Islam, okay, as as I've explained
before, the two are really synonymous,
Sharia and Islam. So as the goal is
Islam has to be in charge of the world,
okay, and dominate it. That's it.
Whether you want to stay as an infidel
and pay tribute, that's your affair.
So
the abode of Islam and the abode of
war, abode of Islam is the Islamic
world, abode of war is the land where
the non-Muslim lives, okay, and it's
called the abode of war cuz that's where
you go and wage war until it gets
subsumed into the abode of Islam and
it's governed by Sharia, okay? So that
is the classic idea that's never
changed.
That's still the codified worldview of
Islam. What I just described is constant
warfare, which
the hostility is there, okay, and the
deception is there because war is
deceit, but we're not necessarily going
to fight you because you're stronger
than us, okay? So as that quote said,
circumstances such that it'd be futile
for the Muslim world to declare war on
the world right now seeing how weak it
is realistically. People forget how
really weak the Muslim world is when
they because they see Muslims
terrorizing Westerners all the time.
It's nothing to do with Muslim strength.
It has to do with the Western, I don't
know, complicity, stupidity. I think
stupidity is giving them a break when we
say that. But be that as it may, let me
continue.
So here's a nice quote from the Muslim
historian and anthropologist Ibn
Khaldun. I actually like reading his
stuff. He died around 1406. And here's a
quote where he clearly articulates this
division that I'm telling you. He
writes, "Quote, in the Muslim community,
jihad is a in the Muslim ummah, in other
words, jihad is a religious duty because
of the universalism of the Muslim
mission and the obligation to convert
everybody to Islam either by persuasion
or by force.
The other religious groups did not have
a universal mission.
And the jihad was not a religious duty
for them save only for purposes of
defense. But Islam is under obligation
to gain power over other nations, okay?
Now I know he said the Muslim the Muslim
mission and obligation to convert
everybody to Islam either by persuasion
by force may seem to contradict what I
said, but later on he also makes clear
that the people of the book can pay
tribute and pay jizya and still not
convert, okay? But you have to also
understand the idea of jizya is to make
them convert. There's a reason the logic
of Islam is this, okay? You as a Jew or
a Christian, fine, we'll take money and
enjoy the money and we'll push you
around and you can be a second class
citizen. And we know in doing that
you're not going to like it, okay? So
eventually you or your progeny are
probably going to convert and come
around and see the light, okay? So that
is also why he phrased it that way
because the mission is to get everyone
to convert. But it's sufficient to at
least make sure that sharia governs and
you can live if if you can tolerate it,
you can live as a dhimmi, okay? Which
not not many people could tolerate.
That's why
the Muslim world,
which used to be most of it at least
MENA, Middle East North Africa, which
used to be the Christian world, is no
longer. It's primarily Muslim,
overwhelmingly. Why? Because it wasn't
easy to be a Dhimmi and constantly pay
money you didn't have and then
afterwards be mistreated socially and
oppressed. So, that's a lot of people
saw the light of Islam and converted
over the centuries, okay?
Bring back
and the
righteousness.